[Musik]
es war eine hölle und das war ein himmel
ein konsumparadies
schnellen trost gab es zu kaufen rasche
linderung und die endgültige erlösung
von allem schmerz den goldenen schuss
zürich letten 1993
insel des elends in einem eher des
reichtums
hier traf ich sie zum ersten mal die
tochter aus gutem haus 27 jahre alte
arzt gehilfen die da im dreck fühlte es
sollte eine lange geschichte werden
ursula
wir werden
das ist mir
verschließt es daheim honig osten
aber nicht blöd da weiß ich wie es kommt
im idyllischen
und so
gesunder ecke das asyl an der drogen
front klinik für drogenabhängige und
aids-kranke ein asyl auch für ursula
immer wieder
ursula seit bald zehn jahren
drogenabhängig mit 17 gekifft dann
amphetamine ein freund lieferte sie mit
20 heroin kokain und so weiter
abszesse alte blut seit jahren ist sie
obdachlos zu hause ging es nicht mehr
stehlen betrügen besserung schweren
absturz sie lebt vom betteln und stehlen
nur prostituierte hat sie sich nie in
ihren körper lang die geliebte nadel ein
sonst nichts ursula pendelt gasse
notschlafstelle so ne ecke krankheit
heißt auch etwas ruhe heißt zeit
trostlose zeit
gemacht so gar nicht gerne bewies und in
rheine mit
aber ich schaffe es einfach nicht
[Musik]
ja
und er ist
und bleibt
dass ich ja die ganze ohnmacht noch
teils wenn es
nötig dass ein geschäft das unternehmen
hätte irgendwie problem können ab größe
und da mit dem ganzen drogenproblemen
ich bin einfach der ohnmächtig und
deine liebe und das war schlecht drauf
sich in bezug auf dem medikament
avastin
nicht was sollte mit
wenn du das kinder vorlesen erst auf der
ober- und
im grund weiß nicht was um geschwächt du
hast mit wasser doch begriff stars da
die banken bestimmt dies kindisch fahre
und benimmt sich nicht wie sie bis auf
die zeit mit besser das tut mir leid
an schneiders und dem verdammt
[Musik]
wer bitte und um dich nach
wasser schaut macht nichts vielleicht
wenig wertigkeit
sieht man sich normal zu sichern
das finde ich jetzt fühlt sich der gast
dir ist bewusst
da lukas
durch
optische und vordenker
[Musik]
wie das spital die speiseröhre verätzt
im drogenrausch truck sie ammoniak sie
meinte es sei methadon
mit
da
sich einfach nicht der punkt
jetzt
peter aufgreifen
stock
beliebte nicht dass das etwas sehr
sicher oder sehr
sicher und sehr geprägt
dass das landratsamt
die wurden knapp die station also wieder
erwachsen geworden
[Musik]
um einen
kompromiss
[Musik]
zwanziger
mitgefühl
so ist es gut
diese längst verkaufte tun
[Musik]
dass mich sind das ist mein eigener ton
das ist meine linken
[Musik]
sein
und jede menge geboten
werden eine große verzerrten umwelt sind
in diesem fall brauchen wir keine
antidot gegen gifte zu spritzen konnten
ihr helfen mit an die frische luft zu
kommen ins spital wollte sie nicht so
wie wir gesagt haben wir haben sie
gefragt ob sie mitspielen möchte
und ich würde dann endgültig an die
polizei abgeben und wunder dass sie das
raumklima
dzl verweigert und
schienen
aber so wohl dass sie eine
persönlichkeit
vorherigen welche drogen gefunden
man setze ich bin selbst nicht
das heute meist zum lachen und dort
nicht um leben und tod ging es diesmal
aber um ein bein beinahe hätte sie es
verloren
stundenlang lag sie bewusstlos in einer
toilette das bein eingeklemmt und kaum
mehr durchblutet
eine notoperation schon fast zu spät
riesige wunden
hauttransplantationen
ursula landet im rollstuhl
zum zweiten mal in ihrem leben lernt
ursula gehen
das ist auch gut so
dann
[Musik]
ja
es wird monate dauern ursula will den
klinikaufenthalt nutzen um die morphin
präparate abzubauen die sie als
ersatzdrogen erhält
[Musik]
ja
die
politik mit
situation genau
weil sich die japaner
das wiege gehoben
werden staubig dem es um gleich mal
etwas für
[Musik]
das ich mir passiert die ganzen tag
fielen tore
[Musik]
was ist geschehen
ich werde es von der nachtschwester
erfahren ursula hatte ausgang und kam
erst frühmorgens zurück
das
alles hat am ganzen körper geschlagen
und dann haben sie immer comeback
gesetzt man hat immer ihre arme hochriss
treffen immer bei der arbeitssuche
blogs immer gesagt ich wollte das nicht
ich wollte das nicht
aus sicherlich so beeindruckend das ist
nicht so schnell vergessen werden wie
sie die nacht ausgesehen hat
ja ich hoffe dass es nicht mehr passiert
vielleicht schafft sie es
wenn erstmal kommt auch schon mit
renault
ja
nie
wer jetzt erst mal nach hinten
bitte
den
auch stellen
freundin
ursula
noch immer fühlst du dich nicht
angenommen nutzlos günstig zu die drogen
waren dich noch nutzloser wie
herauskommen
freunde vermitteln ihr den kontakt zu
einem heim für geistig behinderte kinder
dort ist eine praktikantenstelle frei
ursula hat die morphin präparate
reduziert sie ist weitaus stabiler wird
es reichen für die anspruchsvolle arbeit
mit den behinderten kindern
[Musik]
endlich nach jahren auf der gasse nach
jahren des elends endlich der
silberstreif am horizont
ursula darf zur probezeit antreten
[Musik]
zwei monate lang war sie in der klinik
personal und mit patienten sind zu
freunden geworden
ein neues zuhause ein eigenes zimmer im
kinderheim die ersten eigenen vier wände
nach jahren der obdachlosigkeit der
irrfahrt durch notschlafstellen und
krankenzimmer
bosseler
vollwertiges mitglied eines
erzieherinnen teams
ursula die gebraucht wird die etwas
wichtiges sinnvolles tut die ein
geregeltes leben führt doch
[Musik]
ein abschied es soll der letzte besuch
im zoo ne ecke sein abschied von der
drogenszene von gefährten der gasse
endgültig
[Musik]
es hätte alles so schön sein sollen
warum dieses chaos warum hat sie all
ihre sachen verstreut
warum wird sie immer seltsamer an diesem
abend an meinem geburtstag zu dem ich
sie eingeladen habe
nicht viel
[Musik]
wenig später treffe ich sie bei einem
konzert ihres idols konstantin wecker
der so schrecklich schön vom kokain
sinkt der selber kokste und doch ein
star wurde
[Musik]
noch arbeitet ursula im kinderheim
kurz danach wird sie weglaufen
[Musik]
am weihnachtstag werde ich sie wieder
finden in einer elenden auffangstation
[Musik]
sind stoppen
für die übung wurde konnten
folgen
wetten wieder einmal
[Musik]
ja
denn jetzt
es ist einfach so
raus will intensiver und die spannung
und jonas folger sagen wo vorwiegend wir
oft nichts los sagt nein ich mache aus
forschung
glaubt das ist das ist fertig bringen
und sich völlig ist wie wir und das ist
für mich wieder klar dass sie
dass ich ganz vorne und
noch eine letzte begegnung in einer
psychiatrischen klinik
selbstmordgefährdet eingesperrt
[Musik]
mit der don einmal am tag
tage die nicht enden wer besucht mich
wer telefoniert mehr geht mit mir
spazieren
dann komme ich endlich heraus
eines tages flieht sie ich werde sie
jahrelang nicht mehr sehen
sie hat
für seine juristen mit dass
sich der auch die passiert hat wo ich
sagen
sie haben also
stürzen oder nur so
abstürzt wenn man es halt so seite und
es
nie also meine sie sich immer wieder
gegen die umsetzung wo sie ihre letzte
umbau mit der schaden von ca da habe ich
lehre ist sich zeit noch
72 sie kann nicht einfach aus dem wagen
und
wer seit zwei wochen wurde ich sagen das
ist jetzt mal für die der mensch
verschieden und
dann wieder besser war glaubt weiss ich
nehme mir wo es alles von gleichen und
im luxus sind und ich weiß
wo so leicht weg verschwunden es ist
winter eisig kalt
ursula das kind aus gutem haus
[Musik]
ursula wie konnte es nur so weit kommen
was ist es das dich immer wieder
flüchten lässt bis hart an die schwelle
des todes
was ist es dass dein leben so gebannt
hat
[Musik]
16 april sv ubisoft
18 spiel ist mit dem bau die nachtruhe
ist uns bis circa 36 seit anfang april
es sei ruhig
[Gelächter]
dass ich das dann fix etat
der regierung für ihre studie auf dass
es in den recall geschafft
und sind zu 80
junge war mit kleinkind sucht und weise
und da hat sich gemeldet und ich noch
fünf zähler zurück und der mini heico
ich hätte sich dann intensiver mit dem
befasst und die haut mit
lösen im
fahrersitz natürliche größten die
belastung
mit dem neugeschäft und mit der
modemesse
und fantasierte natürlich nicht ganz
gesund bleibt
kontakte
mit da muss mich damit die bilder
gesehen man muss sich selber vorstellen
dass
damit den takt irgendwas nicht stimmt
dass dort bis mindestens nicht im takt
sich
im wintergarten
die
eigene sexualität
und das ist jetzt so beobachter
und
noch weniger zu zu
den anderen gruppen
das
geschwisterkind gartenbau aber
verbraucht auf dem rücken
also tätig so maus offensichtlich wurde
dass das irgendwo muss ist
aufmerksamkeit
auf sich lenkt und die
frage stellt wie das so ist
denn ihr ziel unserer reise ob sichtbar
wird die ihnen viele kinder
psychiater geschickt so dass
ich das st
in der chemie wird sie
ja und mit
das sagte dass er wenig dass er sehr
hart
das kann ich hoffe mal dass das sehr
wichtig ist dass man das müsse das
müssen sich
ab
es ist das letzte mal dass ich den vater
sehen
[Musik]
es geht es kaum die möglichkeit aus
aussicht ist eine situation aus deiner
kühlung mittels befreien und das ist
müsse der familie nett gemeint der
familie therapie angefangen und die hat
mir abgebrochen
[Musik]
so viel widerstand auftaucht
sind es dass das nicht machbar ist
sechs jahre später meldet sie sich
wieder warum warum darf ich sie auf
einmal wieder filme was will sie mir
zeigen wo steht sie
hat eine eigene wohnung zum ersten mal
in ihrem leben weit weg von der
drogenszene
eine eigene wohnung und so etwas wie
zwei kinder seien und karas
remmel
buch mose
gut sagt sie da jetzt sagte anschließend
besser
und besser geworden
und so langsam aber es ist irgendwie
entwicklung
war es das was ich mir insgeheim all die
jahre erhofft hatte fest steht ursula
hat überlebt
[Musik]
ja
doch 130 2 mio
und
dann ist mit afro also kann die boni
galaform
also wenn du ein bisschen glück
eindruck das ist
wichtig und das ist so viel geld sie als
erster eindruck kommt
nachher noch im tod von vp haben wir ein
zimmer klima also
die wieder um den job
und
riss fühlt sie sich für den wald
geschickt und wollte so
tut als erster linie hausgemacht test
noch dann für mich also praktisch
möglich
ja wenn sie schlecht gegangen ist wenn
ich diese können auf mich zählen
radiologen auf sind
glaube ich dass ich dem gerecht werden
[Musik]
ursula
ausgestiegen
oder forschen mit dem wirklich nur blut
juni ganz gut aber
nur in wirklich vertrauen hast du nicht
bauen haben so dass kaum jemand muss mir
irgendwelche leute für den gast und
das ist für mich
das stimme ich sehe was ich suche wiener
linien insel die wohl nicht so voluminös
und wenn ich mich wieder traktieren und
sagen was gut und was nicht
eines ist geblieben der morgendliche
besuch beim arzt wo sie ihr methadon
erhält immer noch zu viel meint sie aber
es geht nicht ohne ein bisschen
medikamente zum dämpfen manchmal alkohol
und ziemlich viele jobs
einmal in der woche der gang zum
fürsorge amt seit einem knappen jahr
erhält sie eine invalidenrente wegen
schwerer psychischer behinderung
doch
kein leben nach der norm aber auch kein
leben mehr im elend auf der gasse
und trank ganz wichtige sache pc und
ihrer mitte
das prägt natürlich
wenn man das
was er macht und versuche
das fertig bringen
es klingt etwas gesammelt
johann das problem an fast gleicher noch
nicht definiert
kontrollierte machte
torsten habbel für mich kommt
kontrolliert und
exzessiven ich aber natürlich sobald
drogen im spiel sind haben diese theorie
defizit märkisch gott
nicht wenn der bisher sehr gut gemacht
meinte
sammer konsumiert so
fertig
dass
noch mehr afrikaner wenn ein
fußabstreifer muss nicht so weit
ein familienidyll
zerbrechlich wie alle idylle
[Musik]
märz 1000 zu schnell gold bin ich auch
nicht gerne sieht alles gut aus und
kommt mit dem mond und gibst du monitor
familienleben mit super
tun der tiere unglaublich schöne pflanze
große familie
das casino emittenten mit dem spaß
machen das ist
halt aber träumen und liegender
besonders wähle sie sonnen
akzeptiere auch peter brunner und 2000
1000 1000 1000 plätze mit
[Musik]
also wenn ihr hund war die probanden
zunächst
nicht
[Musik]
weiter geht's so lange es geht ursula
und ihr paradox dass mir das jetzt
tue dies lehrt
uns klar wissen mit man aufgerüstet
christus für die
pfarrer sieber mit dem herz für alles
was da kreucht und fleucht
[Musik]
was gibt es noch zu sagen dass das
einzige gewisse die ungewissheit ist
dass die gleise auf denen wir fahren so
zerbrechlich sind
ursula hat ihr zweites kind ihre cayenne
verloren gestohlen vermutlich ursula ist
wieder einmal abgestürzt
und wenn ich das gemacht ja das ist so
ich habe einen kurzschluss sagte das ist
nicht bemerkt sie mit stress und
totaler
nicht stark unterwegs
mal zu locken
zweieinhalb wochen ist denn jetzt weg
ursula hat die hoffnung und fast
verloren
schwer zu sagen wie viele menschen
ursula das leben schon gerettet haben
aber die hunde sind es womöglich die sie
am leben erhalten was ist wenn jane
verschwunden bleibt
[Musik]
noch
seien
[Musik]
doch wie war ich auch da und dort sind
die sieben was er will sagt ich widme
ich mich sagt er
komme ihm noch geld von ihrer zeit wenn
ich sie würde findet dann geht es uns
heute
wohneinheit das körnchen ii musste sich
mit rang zehn jahre
nach dem tod des vaters versuchte ursula
um einen beistand er hilft ihr ordnung
zu schaffen in der wirrnis und zahlungen
und busenwunder abonnement und
rentenbezüge
man
muss fünf mal
so pries ein nebenverdienst
[Applaus]
ein ungeliebter job weil er ursula zur
randständigen stempelt
zum ersten mal seit langer zeit besucht
ursula ihre mutter wieder einmal
gemeinsam mit freund daniel
zwei welten begegnen sich schwarze
afghan trifft viele bedenken
[Musik]
gold
für
verena
sailer
gewann
[Musik]
problem aber durch dörfer verbrauchen
oder der bürger selbst verfasst
mit
[Musik]
nein nein nein ich so gut da durch
den erfolg
behaupteten
[Musik]
diese cornet
wortbedeutungen 17 14
wie heisst
[Musik]
also los